♪ Mac and cheese, mac and cheese, ♪
♪ baby, yes, mac and cheese ♪
Oh, my god, you should do
your mac and cheese dance.
Today I'm gonna be guessing
mac and cheese toppings.
My friend Shannon has to
guess what these flavors are.
And I will be blindfolded.
We don't want to mess up.
- Can you see anything?
- No.
You better be very descriptive.
(dramatic fanfare)
This is new technology.
This is harder than I thought.
It literally is half a
fork and half a spoon.
I forgot that this part's
gonna make me look like an idiot.
Ooooh.
It's crunchy.
Smoky.
Is it more salty?
Let me double-check.
Is it steak?
(buzzer)
It is cheddar-and-ham mac and cheese.
Bacon.
(bell rings)
It's so good.
(laughing)
Mmmm!
Oh my god.
We're here for the mac and cheese.
We're here.
(suspenseful music)
Here we go.
Oh, ho, okay, this is, this
is gonna be a challenge.
First word that comes to mind.
Backyard...fun?
You put it on food on the 4th of July.
- Bananas.
(buzzer)
What, wait?
What are you eating on the 4th of July?
I ate bananas.
So there's onion.
(bell rings)
Oh, yeah, I believe there's a meat.
Okay, so there's a protein.
It's a brown sauce.
Maybe it's a little reddish.
BBQ sauce!
(bell rings)
- Yes!
- Yeah!
Our protein is gonna be...
Cluck, cluck, cluck.
Chicken.
(bells rings)
Yes.
You have to try this.
You're gonna pass away.
Oh my god, is it on my face?
Big fan of this.
Those fried onions, baby.
Okay, let me have some more.
I literally had it for a second.
(suspenseful music)
Last one was a little rough.
Yeah.
- Um...
- Mac and cheese.
- Yes, that's one.
- Um.
You know that thing that
grows in the ground?
Vegetables.
Uh huh, and the thing
that's like purple or white.
Onion.
(bell rings)
This is a garnish.
This is something that makes you fancier.
Rosemary.
(buzzer)
Oh, bell pepper.
No.
Bay leaves.
(buzzer)
- [Man] Oh, my goodness.
- This boy's palate.
Shannon, will you still
be friends with me after?
All he eats, probably,
is like frozen pizza.
No.
Your favorite thing on pizza.
Pepperoni.
No, no.
(buzzer)
OK, this is something I like.
Omega-3s baby!
Salmon.
(buzzer)
Close.
Is it my favorite?
It is your favorite.
Avocado.
(bell rings)
Yeah!
- Pico De Gallo
- Yes.
Woo!
Oh my god.
Mac and cheese is a
foundation for all kinds
of wonderful creations.
Good job, Panera.
[Man] I'll get that for you.
No, no, no, no, no.
Bring them all back. I
want to try each one again.
Mm, mm, mm, mm.
- Oh, good, no, no, no, no.
- Can I have some?
No.
Can I have some?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.